bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france l'avocat de julian
assange a porté plainte contre andorre
cover global déjà son coup d'une enquête
pour espionnage
dans ce cas précis comment la procédure
peut se dérouler écoutez la procédure
est en cours devant l'audience nationale
à madrid qui avec une juridiction pour
le moment qui réunit des éléments de
preuve et qui décidera lorsque l'anc est
pour le moment et secrète certain nombre
d'éléments qui filtrent dans les médias
notamment parce que des témoins sont
entendus c'est le cas de l'avocat
espagnol l'ancien juge d'ailleurs de
julian assange qui vient d'être entendue
au sortir de cette enquête une décision
sera prise de renvoyer des gens pour
être jugé devant une juridiction ou non
il semblerait en effet que les choses
vont avancer parce que le dossier paraît
gagner en consistance et les autorités
espagnoles ont manifestement à coeur de
savoir ce qui s'est vraiment passé
d'attraire les responsables
d'éventuelles infractions de vent devant
la juridiction pénale espagnole parce
que vous dites que le dax gagne en
consistance ajustements l'avocat de
julian assange baltasar garzon il
affirme disposer de multiples preuves
d'enregistrements part à une micro caché
caméras des données aussi de la société
undercover global de témoignages
d'anciens employés ce sont des éléments
essentiels pour appuyer le dossier
d'accusation et convaincre les juges
absolument je pense que les éléments qui
sont réunies je n'ai pas pu les voir
évidemment pour le moment mais les
éléments réunis à ce qu'on comprend sont
très nombreux il y à un certain nombre
de deux témoins qui ont été entendus pas
simplement les victimes de ces
infiltrations et de ces enregistrements
mais également des employés de cette
société qui semble-t-il se serait
retournée contre leur employeur je ne
sais pas ainsi qu'un certain nombre
d'autres éléments qui sont des éléments
de technique je crois comprendre qu'il
ya un grand nombre d'e-mails qui ont pu
être retrouvés de contacts téléphoniques
qui ont pu être établi puis aussi on a
enquêté sur le gérant de cette société
sur monsieur morales et on s'est rendu
compte semble-t-il qu'il allait être
régulièrement aux usa et notamment ce
qui a attiré l'attention qu'il allait en
virginie non loin de là une lime se
trouve le siège de la cia des versements
d'argent aussi très important je crois à
hauteur de près de 20000 euros par mois
ont été ont été identifiés et donc les
éléments comme je le disais en effet
sont en train de de s'accumuler alors
restera la question de savoir est ce
sera sans doute votre question suivante
de savoir comment on va pas pouvoir
connecter morales avec les autorités
américaines directement pour le moment
je crois comprendre qu'il ya des
faisceaux qui laisse penser que le
client ne peut être autre que le
gouvernement américain
plus précisément la cia parce que c'est
la cia qui est visé dans ce dossier là
on verra dans quelle mesure on obtient
des preuves directes un petit peu le le
même processus finalement que pour l'anc
est cachée au buggy ou la question était
de savoir dans quelle mesure on pouvait
connectés ou pas mb s aux faits qui
s'étaient déroulés au sein d'une
ambassade d'ailleurs c'est un dossier de
parallèle avec cet enregistrement qui
avaient été effectuées par les services
de renseignements turcs au sein d'une
ambassade des étrangers sur son sol
en l'occurrence l'ambassade d'arabie
saoudite donc on n'est pas dans le
premier cas hallucinant parce que c'est
tout de même hallucinant
d'enregistrement au sein d'une ambassade
gestion des enquêtes qui parfois arrive
à avancer
évidemment là c'est la mise en cause de
la cia a pas donc ça va pas être simple
mais l'équipe de défense de julian
assange
je pense quand il y aura de pousser
aussi de manière à faire la lumière sur
cette affaire et puis à s'en servir
aussi dans le cadre de la procédure qui
va reprendre au mois de septembre l'ong
le père étant précisé qu'à l'évidence
s'il est démontré que les américains et
les autorités américaines sont impliqués
dans ces faits graves et bien sûr le
volet extradition ça devrait avoir des
conséquences parce que la motivation
politique en tout cas le risque
d'absence de procès équitables pour
julian assange il est extradé aux états
unis sera d'autant plus caractérisés
donc je pense qu'il ya là un enjeu très
important aussi pour la défense
d'assange mois de septembre et la
procédure espagnol nous
ra de façon certaine des arguments de la
défense d'assange en angleterre sur le
procès d'extradition puisque vous
évoquez la faire arracher guy justement
et des liens présumés aussi entre
justement cette société qui est visé par
cette enquête dans le cas de julian
assange et la cia est ce que on peut
imaginer que des instances
internationales demandent aussi une
enquête plus élargir seulement s'il
était établi que les états unis sont
impliqués en tant qu'etat rex n'est pas
simplement l'initiative d'une société
privée
il y aurait possibilité bien entendu
pour les plaignants voire même pour
l'angleterre ne s'est pas l'équateur a
l'air plutôt impliqué dans un premier
temps parce qu'il ya bien deux premiers
espions plage par les équatoriens de
julian assange et puis ensuite il y à
cette personne du travail pour les
équatoriens qui valait doublé qui va se
révéler être apparemment un agent double
mais il y aurait possibilité
éventuellement où il envisager une
saisine par exemple la cour
internationale de justice où évidemment
de se plaindre devant certaines
commissions des droits de l'homme la
difficulté va rester celle et pour avoir
traité un certain nombre de dossiers
dans le pacifique et avec d'autres
agences américaines d'ailleurs que la
cia par exemple la dea
il est il est peu connu les il est
établi que un certain nombre d' agence
américaine et d'autres pays du monde
aussi d'ailleurs emploi ce qu'on appelle
des contractuels c'est à dire que pour
un certain nombre de missions
il ya des choses qui sont faites par des
gens qui ne sont pas directement aux
membres des organisations
gouvernementales mais qui sont à
l'interface entre les autorités
officielles et puis les cibles qui
doivent être visées et je pense que vous
citiez blacks auteurs tout à l'heure où
j'en alizés le rapport avant l'interview
en parlait je crois mon et dans ce type
d'intervention là et je présume que la
cia
l'acea pardon aura fait
diligence pour n'avoir aucun contact
direct avec cette personne qui pour le
moment a l'air de jouer le jeu et de
contester tout lien avec les autorités
américaines dont on verra comment ça
avance enfin on sait que pour nds je
reviens sur ce sujet là les américains
avaient isolé le fait que manifestement
un appel remontant vers le bras droit de
nbs avait tété pâte juste après
l'exécution de cachot dit en indiquant
qu' à ton patron que le travail a été
fait manifestement ça n'a pas eu plus de
conséquences que ça alors qu'on parle là
d'un crime encore plus grave que celui
commis contre julien assange et son
équipe
on a torturé et exécuté un homme dans
une ambassade
aujourd'hui voilà rien ne s'est passé il
a remis ça existe continuer de
fonctionner juste très rapidement mettre
juillet vous parlais tout à l'heure la
procédure d'extradition a lancé par les
états unis à l'encontre de julian
assange qui doit reprendre le 7
septembre à ce que tous ces éléments
peuvent conduire justement un report de
cette procédure d'extradition
écoutez je pense que dès que la plainte
avait été déposée
je crois que c'est en décembre 2019 pour
l'espionnage mais il y avait une plante
antérieures parce qu'il y avait eu une
tentative d'extorsion apparemment sur
sur julian assange donc une plante dès
le mois d'avril 2010 9 avaient été
déposées quand ça avait été le cas
initialement j'avais pensé à un
contre-feu et puis lorsque j'entends le
dossier comme je le disais montée en
consistance
je m'en rends compte que peut-être la
défense d'assange tient quelque chose là
qui qui pourrait être une carte gagnante
sur la motivation politique sans doute
mais aussi je le disais sur le risque de
violation de l'article 6 de la
convention européenne des droits de
l'homme qui garantit le droit à un
procès équitable
et s'il était démontré aux yeux des
juges anglais et bien que les américains
étaient à la manoeuvre dans l' écoute
notamment de tous les rendez-vous de
julian assange avec ses avocats
il y aurait évidemment un risque
important une fois aux états unis dans
les mains du bureau du procureur est
bien que ces conditions de défense
soient considérés comme absolument non
respectueuses de l'article 6 et du droit
au procès équitable donc je pense que
que ce fils l'a en effet va être retirée
et je pense que les juges anglais vont
êtres vont être tout même très très
réceptifs à cette nouvelle ligne
d'arguments temps précisé que peut-être
en effet les magistrats anglais vont
décidé de surseoir une suspende la
procédure comme vous disiez
d'extradition en attendant d'avoir des
conclusions de l'audience nationale
l'anc est pour le moment il secrètement
ça elle a l'air d'avancer tant de robin
merci à vous mouiller m je lui dis je
rappelle que vous êtes avocat en droit
pénal